[Musica]
vi racconto una storia una storia che
posso dire abbia cambiato gli ultimi 19
anni della mia vita
sì perché appunto durante il weekend
pasquale di 19 anni fa mi sono trovato
per caso con degli amici a passare quel
weekend nella spiaggia di rimini quindi
non al lido come dicevano i nostri
speaker ma rimini
magari con l'intento di frequentare
qualche discoteca qualche locale qualche
qualcosa di più tradizionale in realtà
passeggiando per la spiaggia
mi sono accorto che avevano allestito
dei campi delle tribune degli stand e
dei ragazzi inseguivano un disco lo
lanciava la lo prendevano correvano
esultavano gioivano alle volte anche si
disperavano e posso dire che in uno dei
giorni forse più importanti della mia
vita ma nessuno aveva avuto subito dopo
ho commesso anche due tra gli errori più
importanti della mia vita ne ho commessi
altri e per carità però il primo di
questi errori è stato appunto non
chiedere a questi ragazzi cosa stessero
facendo
li ho visti come vi dicevo inseguire un
disco con tanta passione e soprattutto
sulla sabbia voi sapete quanto sia già
difficile camminare sulla sabbia in
realtà loro ci correvano e ci corrono
davvero tanto il secondo il secondo
errore è stato quello di non comprare
questo che è stato solo l'anno dopo il
mio primo crismi il mio primo disco
nella spiaggia di rimini dove da 29 anni
si gioca il torneo più importante della
versione beach quindi su spiaggia di
ultimate frisbee poi in realtà con dei
dischi simili si praticano anche diverse
discipline tra cui il disc golf come
possiamo vedere in questa foto dove al
posto di una mazza di una
pallina di una buca nella versione più
tradizionale del golf che conosciamo
sostituiamo con il nostro braccio un
disco è un cesso un canestro e quindi
partendo da una distanza anche superiore
di 100 metri ci approcciamo alla buca al
cesso al canestro per poi effettuare
l'ultimo lancio che ci permette di
realizzare il punto un'altra disciplina
che si pratica con il disco è il
freestyle vedete come questi atleti con
delle evoluzioni davvero incredibili
associate ad una musica creano una
coreografia che gli permette di avere
una valutazione da parte di una giuria e
di conseguenza di scalare una classifica
e vincere o magari non farlo
un torneo ma quello che ho visto in
quella spiaggia di rimini che mi ha
fatto come vi dicevo cambiare gli ultimi
19 anni della mia vita è stato la
ultimate frisbee questa disciplina che
nella versione più tradizionale quella
giocata sul campo in erba su un campo
outdoor possiamo immaginarlo come un
campo da rugby con due ali di meta
finale dove due squadre composte da
sette giocatori si contendono il disco è
la squadra che attacca cerca di fare un
infinito numero di passaggi per poi
riuscire a realizzare il passaggio
finale all'interno dell'area di meta e
farlo ricevere da un proprio compagno
così da poter realizzare il punto la
squadra in difesa naturalmente cerca di
impedirne il passaggio di impedirne la
ricezione e di effettuare così un
intercetto oppure a far cadere il disco
e quindi passare dalla fase difensiva
alla fase offensiva
vedete questo sport come tutti gli sport
sia di squadra che singoli ma molte
similitudini agli altri appunto quali
insomma la preparazione tecnica
l'allenamento nel nell'imparare a
lanciare un disco ea perfezionare la
propria tecnica piuttosto che il la
preparazione atletica naturalmente
perché sulle dimensioni del campo che vi
ho detto c'è molto da correre da da
saltare come vedete da contendersi la
ricezione del disco ma il rispetto il
rispetto nei confronti dei propri
compagni del proprio capitano del
proprio allenatore
il rispetto del disco ma quelle
peculiarità forse più uniche e
straordinarie che ho visto in quella
spiaggia di rimini
o meglio mi sono reso conto che c'era
qualcosa che non andava ho visto subito
che mancava qualcosa
e c'era qualcosa di diverso mi ferì mi
riferisco innanzitutto alla possibilità
di disputare questa disciplina sia nella
versione maschile nella categoria
maschile e femminile piuttosto che come
vedete nella versione nella categoria
mixed dove le squadre da sette giocatori
sono composte da tre uomini e quattro
donne piuttosto che quattro donne e tre
uomini dove si coniuga perfettamente
quella che è la capacità tecnica e
mentale di una giocatrice femminile con
quella che è la criticità e la fisicità
di un di un atleta maschile e questa
disciplina è quella che ci ha permesso
grazie a un ottimo lavoro della
federazione italiana di entrare a far
parte del coni del comitato olimpico
nazionale del comitato olimpico
internazionale per essere presenti già
dal 2024 nelle future olimpiadi e questo
è il traguardo che forse ogni sport
vorrebbe raggiungere soprattutto gli
sport minori come questo perché vi
faccio una domanda qualcuno di voi aveva
mai sentito parlare di ultimate frisbee
basso 1 beh mi fa piacere perché sono
venuto qui apposta
la seconda straordinaria particolarità
che ho visto su quel su quella spiaggia
su quel campo è stata che mancava
qualcosa mancava mancava la figura di un
arbitro quello che tutti siamo abituati
a vedere conoscere considerare spesso in
una forma protagonistica anche
all'interno di una partita quindi un
arbitro che giudica fischia decide in
questo sport non esiste ma non esiste né
nella partita che facciamo a scuola con
i ragazzini di 11 12 anni né alle finali
del campionato del mondo che si
disputano ogni due anni piuttosto che i
campionati europei campionati italiani
che saranno domani a rimini una tappa
non esiste un arbitro esiste un
regolamento scritto dalla federazione
mondiale negli anni 70 che ha subito
delle migliorie delle varianti delle
perfezioni anche ed è sicuramente quello
che noi andiamo ad insegnare pari passo
con la capacità motoria di lanciare
ricevere prendere inseguire un disco
quando ci rivolgiamo alle scuole medie
alle scuole superiori e facendo i corsi
negli istituti scolastici ci saranno a
breve i campionati studenteschi appunto
quindi insegniamo questo perché è un
aspetto motorio che non sta nelle nostre
corde nel senso noi siamo abituati a
prendere un pallone passarlo con le mani
con i piedi saltare una corda una
capriola ma lanciare un disco non non lo
sappiamo fare non sta nel nostro dna
secoli posso dire
quindi se diamo questo ma pari passo
insegniamo un regolamento ed insegniamo
a questi ragazzi a trovarsi compagni di
squadra di una ragazza quindi voler
vincere la stessa partita con l'aiuto di
una ragazza e soprattutto ad essere per
prima cosa giudici di noi stessi
conoscendo regolamento e sapendo fino a
dove posso spingermi e ad arrivare per
vincere quella partita senza mai per
mettermi di farlo volendo fare un passo
in più di quello che il regolamento mi
permette di fare
vedete voi direte ma ma com'è possibile
come può funzionare questa cosa funziona
perché abbiamo la fortuna di insegnarlo
dei ragazzi di 11 10 12 anni che non
sono forse viziati da quelle che sono le
conoscenze di un arbitro all'interno di
un campo di gioco quindi loro imparano
questo e per fortuna crescono forse
crescono anche dei ragazzi un po più
consapevoli di quello che si può e di
quello che non si può fare ma
soprattutto è supportato da una colonna
portante sulla quale si basa lo sport
con questo disco che si chiama spirito
del gioco lo spirito del gioco
vuol dire che in due parole alla fine di
ogni partita che sia vi ripeto il
campionato studentesco delle scuole
medie piuttosto che la finale di un
campionato del mondo
le due squadre si trovano a centrocampo
come vedete in un abbraccio che serve
principalmente per stemperare gli animi
che spesso si sono accesi perché durante
80 minuti di gioco
può succedere di tutto ma serve perché i
due capitani si confrontano su quello
che è stato l'andamento tecnico tattico
della partita ma anche quello che è
stato il rispetto del regolamento e
rispetto dell'avversario rispetto del
frisbee del disco
subito dopo ogni squadra da un voto alla
squadra avversaria sulla base di quello
che è stato appunto questo rispetto e
questo permette di salire una classifica
di crescere su una classifica
io ho avuto il piacere e l'onore di
vestire la maglia della nazionale
italiana di questo sport che vede in
italia poco meno di duemila atleti e
partecipare ai campionati del mondo in
canada nel 2008
qualche anno fa in danimarca nel 2015
con dei miei compagni con il nostro
capitano alessandro somaini che è un
ragazzo di como che non è qui con noi ma
che lo saluto e abbiamo avuto l'onore di
vincere questa classifica di vincere
questo premio per forse ancor più ambito
di quello che è il premio di quello che
vince il torneo ai punti beh insomma
questo questo spirito del gioco
noi ce l'abbiamo naturalmente lo
impariamo lo portiamo in campo e di
sicuro fa parte della nostra vita lo
portiamo anche nelle nostre vite private
a casa al lavoro con i nostri amici con
le nostre compagne con i nostri compagni
con con un po tutto quello che la nostra
vita cerci ci circonda e vedete spesso
queste peculiarità così uniche secondo
me straordinarie la possibilità di
giocare uomini e donne la mancanza di un
arbitro non si trovano nella vita di
tutti i giorni con questi aspetti così
positivi perché mi riferisco alla
distinzione che spesso si fa
sull'operato di una donna nei confronti
di quello che fa un uomo vero quanto
debba impegnarsi di più una donna per
raggiungere gli stessi risultati dal
punto di vista lavorativo professionale
piuttosto che a scuola piuttosto che in
una compagnia di amici e aggiungo anche
a questo aspetto chiamato giudizio
questo termine che spesso in molti di
noi ci arroghiamo il diritto di di
giudicare di dire di pensare con una
parola con un commento con con questi
social network è ormai sono parte di noi
tutti i giorni e questo giudizio spesso
grava sulle spalle di qualcuno non
facendogli così tanto bene questo
insomma ancora prima di pensare di
essere noi i giudici di noi stessi
quello che noi facciamo in campo noi
siamo noi che ci rendiamo conto quando
abbiamo commesso un'infrazione quando
abbiamo violato regolarmente
durante quella slide prima dove c'erano
quelle due ragazze che discutevano si
stavano confrontando e lo facevano
all'interno di un tempo massimo stimato
e se questo confronto non porta ad una
soluzione
l'azione ricomincia dal lancio
precedente
quindi questi aspetti che non spesso
ritroviamo in maniera così positiva
nella nostra vita privata nella nostra
vita normale di tutti i giorni negli
sport che frequentiamo più più
tradizionali grava sulle nostre spalle
non è così positiva se così posso dire
per questo io quando molti amici e molti
familiari mi dicono andria ma dove vai
in giro per l'italia in canada in
danimarca in tutta europa a giocare un
torneo una partita di frisbee domani
andrò con i miei compagni di squadra
rimini vado a seguire un disco quindi
consiglio un po tutti voi di conoscere
un disco iniziare a lanciarlo prenderlo
guardalo volare perchè sicuramente vi
farà conoscere dei giocatori di ultimate
di ultimate frisbee che saranno in grado
di portare il loro spirito del gioco
nelle vostre vite nei vostri uffici a
casa vostra con le vostre compagne e
portare sicuramente anche un cambiamento
e questo cambiamento sarà sicuramente
positivo e come il titolo di questo the
backs un vento che non discrimina non
sta a guardare un uomo una donna non
giudica sofia spazza e porterà delle
novità positive a tutti voi grazie
grazie
[Applauso]